transition énergétique un terme que l'on
peut lire tous les jours dans la presse
mais comme étant vraiment ce qui se
cachait derrière
alors oui et je vais prendre le risque
de me fâcher dès le départ avec wendy la
fin de l'énergie nucléaire mais comme la
transition énergétique c'est aussi le
soutien aux énergies renouvelables
je pense qu'on va se réconcilier
rapidement mais la transition
énergétique ce n'est pas que cela
je vais tenter de vous l'expliquer nous
sommes nombreux aujourd'hui à voleurs
savoir ce qui se cache derrière
l'étiquette des produits que nous
consommons d'où provient la nourriture
qui nous est servie où et par qui sont
fabriqués les habits que nous portons
mais qui se soucie de savoir ce qu'il ya
derrière l'interrupteur
personne ou presque or tout le monde
devrait s'inquiéter par une véritable
révolution est en cours derrière les
prises électriques révolution dont
l'origine et ça a déjà été évoqué et le
combat que l'on mène face au
réchauffement de la planète pour
combattre les gaz à effet de serre il
faut effectivement changé la manière
dont nous consommons les ressources de
notre planète
nous allons donc changé mais pas
seulement 2 sur nrj nous allons changer
de réseau de distribution de mode de
commercialisation et de comportements de
consommation jusqu'au début de ce
millénaire
l'homme a cherché à satisfaire ses
besoins en énergie en allant puiser les
ressources du sous sol de la terre
c'est ainsi que charbon pétrole gaz
nucléaire sont extraits quotidiennement
de notre planète et nous apporte un
certain confort
aujourd'hui encore ils représentent 85 %
de l'énergie primaire totale du monde à
cela correspond en général une
organisation centralisée organisé en
quasi monopole avec des grands sociétés
qui à travers leur réseau ou distribuent
leur énergie et cela marche relativement
bien
nous avons tous de l'électricité à la
maison nous avons tous du gaz de
l'essence votre confort s'améliore de
jour en jour tous plus râlant nous
lorsque le prix de l'essence frôlé de
francs la station essence
alors pourquoi veux tu ont changé cet
ordre établi
et bien parce que les énergies fossiles
on en veut plus elles sont limitées et
polluante et le monde entier se tournent
actuellement vers les énergies
renouvelables
nicolas a dit en début de set et dick ce
que les dinosaures avaient disparu alors
c'est pas tout à fait vrai nom de
l'énergie il y en encore quelques-uns
sertic qui pensent que c'est un
épiphénomène
pour ma part je suis convaincu du
contraire les énergies non renouvelables
c'est le futur et pour s'en convaincre
il suffit de regarder ce qui se passe
dans les pays qui nous entourent pour
portugal 25 % de l'électricité produite
par des éoliennes en autriche 9 %
provient des installations de biomasse
et c'est le photovoltaïque qui en italie
produit 8 % de l'énergie consommée dans
le pays
il faut dire que le renouvelable
contrairement aux énergies fossiles a un
potentiel inégalé
vous savez peut-être mais en une heure
le soleil des livres à la terre la
quantité d'énergie que l'humanité
utilise durant une année
ce chiffre est assez hallucinant et mon
esprit d'ingénieurs me fait penser qu'
on ne va pas attendre longtemps avant
d'être capable non seulement de capter
mais surtout de stocker efficacement
cette énergie et c'est là tout l'enjeu
des énergies renouvelables il va falloir
changer notre comportement ne pourront
plus être de simples consommateurs
passifs qui attend patiemment
l'électricité arrive dans son salon il
en va de même également pour les
sociétés de distribution de production
où nos politiques
elles ne pourront plus se contenter de
tranquillement acheminer les électrons
jusque derrière nos prises le nouveau
système qui se dessine est ouvert
décentralisée et offre un rôle à chacun
d'entre nous
et en particulier aux entreprises le
secteur de la construction
jusqu'à présent les artisans continue à
délivrer des prestations je dirais
traditionnel câblage électrique pose de
chauffage couverture de toiture
certes les matériaux les outils les
techniques ont évolué au cours du temps
mais le business est resté quasiment
identiques et aujourd'hui avec une
croissance accrue d'un côté et d'autre
part une pression législative toujours
plus restrictives et lendemain s'annonce
moins rose
alors oui la mutation du paysage
énergétique offrent une réelle deuxième
chance pour les entreprises du secteur
de la construction avec le changement
paradis qui s'annonce elles vont pouvoir
proposer avec succès des produits et des
services innovants
je pense par exemple à la domotique ou
smart rom pour sa plus chic qui
permettra d'optimiser le fonctionnement
de nos appareils électroménagers
je pense aux panneaux thermiques qui
couplé à des grands accumulateurs l'eau
chaude viseront à nous rendre
indépendant en matière de salaires ou
encore aucune photovoltaïque de couleurs
qui s'intégreront harmonieusement dans
notre architecture pris certaines
entreprises ont déjà fait un pas dans
cette direction
je constate malheureusement que ce n'est
pas la majorité d'entre elles lorsque je
parcours l'annuaire des entreprises
actives dans la branche photovoltaïque
en suisse et que je constate que seuls
dix entreprises sont répertoriés dans le
valais romand
je me pose de sérieuses questions n'y
aurait-il pas assez de soleil en valais
on arrive on nous pas à lever les yeux
pour le voir sur le terrain
j'entends beaucoup de personnes qui
cherche plutôt des prétextes pour
attendre plutôt que des motivations pour
avancer il ya des gens
qui n'avance le coût de la formation
kim avance la crainte d'être
approvisionné par des énergies
intermittentes le risque de perdre des
emplois
il ya des gens qui sont contre par
principe
puis le pire c'est ce qui me disent on
va pas changer
on a toujours fait comme ça
et certains reposant ouais c'est facile
pour toi de parler projets d'énergie
renouvelable c'est ton métier
nous on n'y comprend rien alors ceci me
donne à faire une petite digression
philosophique il ya quelques années
encore moi non plus vous n'y comprenez
rien aux énergies renouvelables
malgré une formation assez généraliste
de l'école polytechnique fédérale de
lausanne
mais mon unité de mesure quotidienne
était plutôt le micro hâte que le
mégawatt puisque j'avais une
spécialisation en microélectronique et
ensuite j'étais actif pendant dix ans la
direction technique d'une entreprise
active dans les systèmes de cartes à
puce donc rien à voir avec l'énergie
puis en 2009 à la proche de la
quarantaine j'ai décidé de le
perfectionner en management de reprendre
des études et je me suis inscrit un
executive mba et cinq semaines en me
rendant en cours je passais devant les
deux et nous les deux éoliennes
nouvellement construites au coude du
rhône et je regardais ses machines avec
fascination
elle représentait pour moi le symbole de
la créativité du savoir-faire de l'homme
capable de dompter souvent contre lequel
augreilh les gens du coin
quelques mois plus tard sans qu'il n'a
aucune velléité vouloir changer de
travail
je suis tombé sur une annonce pour un
poste de responsable d'un département
renouvelables et je me suis posé
quelques questions d'un côté j'avais
l'envié d'y aller parce que je me disais
tiens pouvoir participer à la
construction peut-être de nouvelles
éoliennes ça doit être très intéressant
et puis d'un autre côté j'avais quand
même un peu peur de ne pas arriver à
assumer tous mes engagements
il faut dire que j'étais en formation
continue que j'étais et je suis toujours
leur papa de trois enfants qui avaient
alors entre 9 et 12 ans et que j'étais
passablement impliqué dans la vie
associative locale
la musique donc responsable d'une
société de développement comme membre de
commissions scolaires mais finalement
j'ai décidé de franchir le pas j'ai
postulé et jean claude job je dois vous
dites les premiers mois ça n'a pas été
facile
contrairement au bel x je n'étais pas
tombé dans la marmite
des potions des énergies renouvelables
et j'ai dû tout apprendre je ne
connaissais rien au photovoltaïque au
turbinage pause éoliennes mais je me
suis accrochée et je m'étais donné 18
mois pour devenir un interlocuteur
crédible en la matière
à ma grande satisfaction ça a pris un
petit peu moins de temps que prévu et le
fait que je sois là ce soir me laisse
penser ou espérer que je suis toujours
un interlocuteur crédible en la matière
alors oui j'ai vécu cette transition
personnelle qui m'a amené vers un monde
différent que je ne connaissais pas et
cette transition comme tout changement
existent de quitter sa zone de confort
et quitter sa zone de confort
ce n'est pas simple cela demande
quelques sacrifices
je me souviens de certaines journées
ensoleillées d'hiver où je passais mon
temps dans mon bureau à étudier plutôt
que de dévaler les pentes enneigées qui
se présentait devant ma fenêtre et je
peux vous dire qu'il y avait quelques
jurons qui retentissaient dans mon
bureau au niveau familial aussi c'était
pas ça j'avais peu de disponibilité peu
de temps à consacrer à mes enfants et
mon épouse mais sur ce plan là je dois
reconnaître que j'ai été gâtée la femme
sarah may ont toujours soutenu dans des
activités et mais ont toujours
brillamment remplacé dans mes tâches
familiales
alors oui quitter sa zone de confort
n'est pas simple et à l'instar de mon
parcours je pense qu'aujourd'hui les
entreprises doivent se remettre en
question elles doivent quitter cette
situation certes maîtrisée nous
potentiel limité et se projeter dans un
avenir avec plein de possibilités mais
progresser cela signifie à contre
affronter nos monstres la peur de
l'échec
la crainte de s'investir l'appréhension
de ne pas maîtriser les choses où la
tentation de la paresse transition
énergétique requiert des idées de
l'innovation et du savoir faire la
technologie mais surtout de l'audace et
du courage
et ce d'autant plus ici en valais où
l'industrie hydroélectrique est si
fortement présente est ancré dans notre
culture
on pourrait se poser la question et il y
en a beaucoup qui cela pose mais
pourquoi faire tant d'efforts pour
produire quelques malheureux kilowatts
heures supplémentaires alors que le
turbinage de l'or bleu en produit plus
de 10 milliards par année et à tenir un
tel raisonnement est non seulement faux
mais il également lâche et risque est
faux car opposé la grande hydraulique
aux nouvelles énergies renouvelables
c'est se tromper de cible
si on veut remplacer les énergies
fossiles
nous ne pouvons pas nous satisfaire de
situation actuelle et à la production de
la grande hydraulique
il convient d'ajouter tout kilowattheure
verts supplémentaires
lascars si on fait rien on confie le
futur énergétique de la planète à
quelques dirigeants
et si les choses ne se passent pas comme
on veut on adopte la politique de
l'autruche risque et enfin parce que ce
marché évolue très vite et le train ne
repassera pas une deuxième fois
attendre et ne rien faire c'est une
erreur nous pouvons tous agir pour aller
dans cette direction
la transition énergétique c'est une
chance inouïe parce qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes libérés de certaines contraintes
et nous avons la possibilité d'agir et
de choisir
est-ce que je roule à l'essence ou
est-ce que je passe sur une voiture
électrique est ce que je veux produire
une partie d'électricité que je consorts
et même constituer une communauté
d'autoconsommation dans mon immeuble
dans le quartier
est-ce que je vais utiliser le bois de
la forêt pour chauffer ma maison il est
normal que face à ses choix
ne soyons un petit peu décontenancé
parce que nous passons d'une situation
le consommateur en général associé à
pollueur payeur à une situation de pro
sommateurs impro sommateurs et quelqu'un
on prend part à la production du produit
qu'ils consomment ce néologisme est en
effet formé duo pro production et son
matin son batteur consommateurs pardon
donc un pro sommateurs est quelqu'un qui
cherche à obtenir un produit un service
qui soit faire sa mesure qui
correspondent à sa propre individualité
et comme je les dis ces choix sont
difficiles parce que le monde de
l'énergie est un monde encore très
technique qui demande à être vulgarisée
un ami responsable d'une agence de
communication vise et dernièrement le
monde de l'énergie
c'est un no man's land marketing et il a
entièrement raison
il reste tout à faire pour que nous
approprions toutes les subtilités de ce
monde et lorsque ce sera fait votre
rapport à l'énergie va considérablement
changer
je suis prêt à prendre les paris que
dans très peu de temps
nous n'allons plus payer leurs factures
de kilowatts heure ou deux mètres cubes
d'eau chaude consommer mais qu'il y aura
des forfaits nrj tout compris à l'image
de ce qui se fait dans le domaine de
téléphone télé internet lorsque nos
enfants construiront ils ne se
contenteront plus de demander un simple
raccordement au réseau électrique au gaz
ils vont faire la traque aux gaspillages
de tout kilowattheure des panneaux
solaires seront systématiquement
intégrée dans les bâtiments des pompes à
chaleur moderne remplaceront
avantageusement des vieux chauffe eau ou
des saulières dépassé mais pour y
parvenir il faut oser il faut prendre de
risques il faut entreprendre et cela à
tous niveaux de la société
que ce soit les instances politiques des
acteurs économiques et professionnels de
la branche vous 1
tout le monde doit s'y mettre et s'il ya
quelques minutes
je dressait un portrait un peu
pessimiste de la situation dans notre
canton
je ne saurais conclure sans évoquer
quelques éléments qui donnent confiance
lorsque je vois ce qui est fait au
niveau de la formation notamment au
niveau de la haute école valaisanne
quand je pense
allez pfl et aux start up qui manqueront
pas d'être créée quand je croise des
entrepreneurs qui transforment leur
entreprise dans cette nouvelle réalité
ou quand j'entends des discours
politiques résolument tourné dans cette
transition énergétique
j'ai confiance j'ai confiance que le
valais saura prendre son destin maman et
ne pas se laisser distancer dans cette
marche ou plutôt cette course vers un
monde différent plus respectueux de
l'environnement
mais encore une fois il faut oser
essayer apprendre et apprendre ce n'est
pas facile
aucune machine ne peut le faire à votre
place aucune pilule peut apprendre pour
nous quelle que soit la méthode
d'enseignement
quel que soit le charisme des
professeurs quels que soient les progrès
que peuvent nous apporter les nouvelles
technologies il faut mouiller le maillot
comme on dit dans le langage sportif il
faut se lancer cheminée coûte que coûte
et ce chemin vous la peine parce que à
prendre certains risques non pas de la
voir mais de l'être
que ce soit à savoir jouer d'un
instrument pratique un sport pour être
un pays
maîtrise une technologie à prendre
développe ce qu'il ya de meilleur en
l'homme la curiosité l'ouverture la
passion le partage montaigne disait à
prendre c'est l'art d'entretenir dans
son âge adulte
le feu allumé chez l'enfant c'est
pourquoi je me plais entretenir ce feu
et j'espère ce soir avoir contribué en
allumer de nouveau
[Applaudissements]